doch durch die hoffnung schon beherzt
willkommen zu einem neuen video liebe
bürgerinnen der schweiz österreichs
deutschlands und wochen wir gerade
herkommt wo kommt eigentlich der
stationen rhein heute ein video liebe
leute was sich sehr viele schon sehr
lange gewünscht haben und wo ich mir
gedacht heute ist genau die richtige
zeit dafür und zwar ein break mit mühe
das heißt natürlich das heutige video
wird so sein dass ich ernsthaft über das
thema real das heißt ich mache nicht so
viele späße wenn ihr also jetzt gerade
der stimmung sagt dass er lieber was
leichtes sehen wollt ihr was lustiges
sehen wollt dann ist auch cool wenn ihr
euch das video nicht rein zieht aber ich
habe das sehr wichtiges zu sagen und
zwar weil da habt ihr am titel schon
gesehen dass das ganze video auch
irgendwie so bisher in diesen slogan
paul skandalen drehen wird aber
vielleicht nicht in der art und weise
wie ihr denkt ich war gestern den
youtube grenze unterwegs heute habe noch
ein paar videos reingezogen und habe ich
gesehen dass auf platz eins und platz
zwei videos zu logen pollmann dachten so
krass anteil der skandal ist lange her
okay deshalb überhaupt nicht gleich zwei
wochen oder so aber ist halt schon so
krass viele videos dazu gekommen und ich
dachte okay jetzt ist das ganze hörer
gesättigt scheint ich vorher noch eine
sache die vielleicht auch gesehen habe
gestern abend waren age creature i
fucking zungenbrecher productions platz
eins der deutschen charts die ich auch
sehr gerne schaue ich liebe diesen kanal
schon seit ewigkeiten bund hier auch
nochmal diese ganze sache mit logen paul
aufbereitet haben eine sache gesagt die
mich sehr beschäftigt hat und die ich
gern in diesem video besprechen möchte
ich muss an der stelle gestehen dass mir
glaube ich keine einziges video was du
diesen logan politskandal kommentiert
reingezogen haben dementsprechend hofft
einfach dass die sache die ich heute
ansprechen werden und ist schon von
irgendeinem mega breit getreten wurde
dass ich jetzt denkt die gehälter
pfänden
ihr kennt ja die ganze geschichte da
muss niemand breittreten gelogen paul
hat eine leiche gefilmt bla bla bla bla
das video trotzdem hochgeladen pipapo
aber ich finde mit die schockierendste
sache daran war das und das ist auch der
grund warum ich dieses video heute mache
dieses video bevor dieser ganze aufruhr
kann dieser ganze shitstorm kam einfach
550 bis 600 tausend likes hatte dieses
video in dem logan paul eine leiche
gefilmt hat darüber geredet hat wie die
hände von der leiche
da sind und sich direkt daneben gestellt
hat und vollkommen falsch umgegangen
späße gemacht hat und so hatte 550 bis
600 tausend lies das heißt 600.000 junge
menschen rund um die welt herum haben
sich gedacht hey und ganz normales video
von logan damit ist eigentlich falsch
das erinnert mich jetzt gerade eine
andere geschichte nicht an der stelle
auch immer als beispiel bringen möchte
und zwar heute ich habe persönlich
nichts gegen gewalt ist jetzt nicht
warum ich darüber rede aber erinnert ihr
euch noch an geld ist geld bald dieses
outplacement hochgeladen was natürlich
auch bisschen falsch war klar alkohol
werbung für minderjährige und sophia
wobei es mal dass leute das nicht
überreden aber genau die gleiche sache
das video hatte bis dieser chat vollauf
mit dem anderen youtuber da
veröffentlicht wurde wo er weiter
geschrieben hat ja scheiß drauf geld
dass geld mir egal
auch ganz normal bewertungen erkennt ja
dass leute das ist irgendwie immer das
gleiche ich glaube communitys von
gewissen youtube schaffen das nicht mehr
so wirklich kritisch darüber
nachzudenken was dieser youtuber macht
und das ist in meinen augen eine
ziemlich erschreckende sache ich habe
mir selbst den eindruck dass sich die
community haben eben auch weil ich mich
auch mal nachdenklich zeit und die haben
wir selbst kritisch äußere ihr eben auch
so sein dass ihr sagt okay wenn ich
irgendwas an mir stört dann erst mal
merkte dies überhaupt dass irgendwas
stört und dann sagt es mir in der regel
auch auf twitter um keine aber irgendwie
konstruktive kritik wie du kuchen sowie
wisst was ich meine leute aber ich finde
das einfach krass und ich finde diese
vorstellung so heftig dass man sich
denkt okay das ist jetzt das jetzt ein
jackpot der ist jetzt keine ahnung
welche youtuber auch immer in
deutschland ich weiß nicht da gebe
bean und die haben einfach eine recht
große gruppe an menschen die
wahrscheinlich sind macht was diese
person sagt und ich weiß nicht ob es nur
mir so geht leute aber denkt mal darüber
nach was für dir so selbst dabei wenn
ihr von menschen denkt oder wisst die
können ja vielleicht selbst gar nicht
mehr so wirklich darüber nachdenken was
da eigentlich passiert wenn jetzt ihr
lieblings youtuber irgendwas sagt und
die folgen die man einfach blind und den
kopf ist einfach vollkommen
ausgeschaltet ist also für mich
persönlich ist das eine echt klasse
vorstellung
ich habe das gefühl dass über dieses
thema nicht genug nachgedacht wird ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt gerade gar nicht wo
ich hin will mit diesem video aber ich
möchte noch zwei sachen sagen wollte ich
glaube dass zwei gruppen von personen
über dieses thema nachdenken müssen
erster gruppe youtuber ich weiß nicht ob
man das als außenstehender verstehen
kann aber so als youtuber ist was
wirklich einfach so man sitzt in seinem
zimmer
man sitzt auf seiner couch und labert
irgendwas neben der kamera und das ist
eigentlich unmöglich zu verstehen wie
die leute da draußen die die eigenen
videos schauen wirklich über einen
selbst denken und wie sehr die einen
mögen man hat irgendwie kein gefühl
dafür aber es ist so wichtig da für ein
gefühl zu haben und wirklich darüber
nachzudenken dass gerade wenn man so
eine art community hat man wirklich
einige leute hat die richtig viel für
ihn machen würden und ein überall hin
folgen würden und das heißt dann
gleichzeitig ist meine verantwortung für
diese leute hat und die nicht überall
hinschicken kann einfach so weil die
selbst das vielleicht in dem moment kann
ich sogar denken andererseits für die
zuschauer heißt es ich kann es ja auch
verstehen wenn man irgendwie so eine
person so richtig anhimmelt das ist klar
ist das geil man sagte mir ich liebe
vieh oder ich liebe dich liebe finden
kliemann oder ich liebe dich kein spaß
beiseite wirklichkeit verstehen dass es
richtig cool ist eine person so
anzuhimmeln aber trotzdem muss man immer
noch kritischen hintergedanken bewahren
weil das das ist was uns menschen
ausmacht dass wir dinge reflektieren
können dass wir dinge kritisch befragen
können dass wir eben nicht wie die
lemminge einfach die klappe runter
rennen mit einer for rent ich weiß nicht
ob das jetzt so ganz über gekommen ist
das thema aber meine zwei wünsche sind
in diese richtung eben youtuber bedenkt
dass es leute gibt da draußen durch
blind folgen und zuschauer und fans
denkt auch immer ein bisschen mit wie es
wichtig das wort von einer person für
euch ist und wie sehr dass euch
beeinflusst und ob es auch unbedingt so
gut ist dass es so ist das ist in meinen
augen das was man aus dem logenplatz
kann dann lernen muss